une question que je me pose toujours
c'est comment est ce que je fais pour
être toujours temps bordélique je sais
pas comment c'est chez vous mais chez
moi c'est toujours un peu le bazar entre
l'ordinateur les téléphones un peu de
tous les côtés ça c'est la fiche pour la
vidéo de tout de suite donc je vais vous
parler d'un il ya toujours un peu pareil
on va se parler de ça aujourd'hui
regardez là on va se parler du s20 du
raisin plus le zoom ultra j'en ai déjà
parlé je vous parle également sur
instagram de lui là le disque dur avec
le capteur d'empreintes digitales
c'est le ssd c'est le cas et cette tâche
et ça j'en ai déjà parlé aux jo que
c'est le à 71 mais aujourd'hui je vous
réserve un truc très exceptionnel c'est
ça qu'est ce que vous savez ce que c'est
que ça ça c'est la borne d'arcade
monsieur gros et ça ça envoie du bois
c'est énorme
alors je vous montrerai lors du studio
tour montrait très rapidement c'est une
boîte française qui m'a fait ça qui
s'appelle flex arcade
ils font des banques complètement
paralysé ses taux d'intérêt ce je vous
mettrai en rien la description ce qu'ils
font c'est complètement difficile alors
si c'est un petit peu mégalomane avec
des photos de monsieur grues partout
mais la craie à elle assez rigolote et
dans le cloud c'est vachement cool voyez
c'est rétro éclairé et même de l'autre
côté vous avez du monsieur heureux il ya
8000 jeu et je peux venir choisir par
console donc les atari pied
retrouvailles de la gabegie rejet de la
gameboy gameboy advance gamble couleurs
sega master system j'ai de la megadrive
j'habite à 2,64 à touques et officines
j'ai la preuve et nintendo j'ai même dû
doucher de la playstation la super
nintendo
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va pas parler de consoles
on va pas parler de je vois la
reconnaissance du visage ont laissé
faire les choses bien
aujourd'hui on va se parler dans toute
assez cool c'est la différence qu'on va
voir
entre deux smartphones parce qu'ils se
ressemblent énormément c'est le galaxy s
20 et le galaxy s g plus les deux
produits sont vraiment très similaires
on va voir surtout six points de
différence 6 points qui vont vous
permettre de faire votre choix et pour
vous aider un petit peu à démêler tout
ça j'ai fait mon travail
tout est là dessus alors voilà je vous
laisse ça fait un arrêt sur image tech
vous pouvez lire bon courage
sauf si vous êtes égyptologue et vous
savez lire les hiéroglyphes dans le cas
contraire je vous invite à regarder
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout vous allez
voir quand fait sur les six points il y
en a en fait très peu qui vont permettre
à montrer la différence entre ces deux
smartphones veut donc pour vous dire
vous invite à visionner cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout et dès maintenant à
baisser
des jolis pouces et a marqué toutes vos
questions ou interrogations suggestions
tout ce qui pourrait aider et apporter
au débat bien évidemment en bas en
commentaire
on a donc six points de différence 6
points qui vont vraiment être important
pour savoir quel smartphone choisir
entre le s20 et le s20 plus le premier
point c'est bien évidemment le format
parce que oui entre es20 à es22 plus
vous avez une différence de format on a
donc un modèle qui est plus grands qui
prendra un peu plus de place tandis que
le vin est un modèle légèrement plus
petits bonds il n'y a pas grand chose et
une petite différence de voyez là je
peux poser l'un soit pour vous puissiez
réellement vous rendre compte
la différence elle est pas
extraordinaire mais elle existe quand
même donc ça dépend effectivement de la
taille de vos mains pour moi le s20 il
fonctionne il va être un peu plus grand
dans votre poche il prendra un peu plus
de place mais il fera la faire si par
contre vous avez des petites mains que
vous avez des petites peuvent vous avez
un petit sac à main ne voulez pas vous
embêter le s20 c'est un très très bon
format alors appris aussi une différence
en termes de couleurs sur les 20 joueurs
trouver un modèle gris je retrouvais
modèle bleu ciel et je trouve un modèle
heureuse ici j'aurais pas de modèle noir
le modèle noir je veux la voir sur le
s20 plus eu donc avoir le gris que je
peux retrouver des deux côtés le noir
qui sera une exclusivité s20 plus j'ai
trouvé le bleu ciel leur hausse par
contre c'est une exclusivité s20 on peut
donc utiliser le s20 beaucoup plus
facilement à une main pour mener un
magnet on a peu de tous les côtés sans
prendre de risque par rapport au reste
bien plus qu'il sera un peu plus grands
qui ce faire il est quand même maniable
mais bon c'est pas tout à fait le même
format ça se fait on prend un peu plus
de risques
le deuxième point qui fait la différence
est un peu lié au format mais pas
complètement
c'est la taille de l'écran on a
exactement le même écran mais ça ne va
juste être la taille qui va ici changé
dans tous les cas il y avait un écran
infiniti dans tous les cas c'est du
dynamic amoled
dans tous les cas vous avez un corning
gorilla glass 6 dans tous les cas vous
avez un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz dans tous
les cas vous avez une résolution de 2300
par 1440 pixels
ça c'est vrai pas vrai parce que si vous
êtes sûre du sens inverse ce qui est mon
cas ici et que vous voulez passer
ensuite en résolution maximale en 3200
par 1440
et bien c'est pas possible vous serez
uniquement en full hd plus si vous venez
sélectionnés y retrouver sur du 60 hertz
vous n'allez pas pouvoir avoir le wqs
des plus aisés fabregas en même temps ça
c'est à vous de voir maintenant sûr de
choisir entre les deux mois ce que je
conseille quand même c'est de rester sur
le fhd plus ne pas avoir une très très
grosse différence entre le fh des plus
et le wqs des plus mais par contre sans
drm venir vachement à porte et puis
c'est surtout un des gros gros gros
point qu'on va retrouver sur tous les
smartphones haut de gamme en 2020 donc
en fait vous êtes en 2004 100 par 1080
vous êtes dans les deux cas sur un ratio
vingt neuvième vais dans les deux cas
une luminosité qui est au top des
couleurs qui sont magnifiques des
contraste infini et des noirs pop mais
la différence que vous allez avoir c'est
que sur le s20 vous allez avoir un écran
de 6,2 pouces tandis que sur le s20 plus
vous avez un écran de 6,7 tous
alors maintenant que la différence est
suffisamment significatives entre ces
deux formats 6 2 et 6 2 7 pouces pour
que ce soit une vraie décision d'acheter
avec ça vous oriente vraiment sur un
modèle plutôt que sur l'autre c'est pas
hyper évident parce qu'en fait si vous
voulez ça se tient vraiment à pas grand
chose les deux smartphones se
ressemblent énormément et pour cause
vous avez le même écran tout est
quasiment pareil donc forcément vous
avez pas vraiment voir la différence 6 2
6 7
il ya une différence allait là elle
existe c'est pour ça que je vous dis que
le format rejoint à l'écran parce que
c'est pas la qualité de la dalle qui
fait différente on a exactement la même
dalle calibrer la même manière sur le
s20 la densité pixels sera un peu plus
élevé mais sinon voilà on nous ça
changera absolument rien la question
continue donc à se poser sans format est
pas réellement sur l'écran on peut donc
dès maintenant dire que le deuxième
point à savoir l'écran on s'en fout et
on renforce ici le point du format un
autre point de différence que vous allez
voir ça va être la batterie attention je
vous parle bien ici de batterie mais pas
d'autonomie
pourquoi parce que sur le s ventes vous
avez une batterie de 4000 militants
paire eur j'ai besoin d'être prof à la
fac quand je fais ça tandis que sur le
s20 plus vous avez une batterie de 4500
milliampères heures ici par contre vous
avez un écran qui est plus petit une
fois de plus est ici vous avez un écran
qui est plus grand donc il va
potentiellement consommer davantage
on avait fait la réflexion lorsque
j'avais parlé du samsung galaxy ace va
ultra glam et les publier le test et je
vous donnais deux jours d'autonomie
on m'avait dit ok comment toi tu peux
trouver deux jours d'autonomie alors que
beaucoup de tests font état d'un jours
d'autonomie c'est qu'en fait ça dépend
effectivement de votre utilisation on
peut arriver à deux jours je dis pas que
vous allez vous arrivez à deux jours
parce que ça dépend plus de votre
utilisation et c'est toujours très
délicat
il ya effectivement des médias qui vont
faire des tests avec différents
logiciels différents protocoles et moi
je parle du principe d usage
je pars du principe que vous avez
utilisé dans un cas dans un autre caïd
ça dépend bien évidemment comment vous
allez utiliser
quelles sont les applications vous allez
utiliser à quel moment vous n'avez pas
utiliser vos smartphones de la même
manière le week-end vous allez être
probablement plus dessus que la journée
vous êtes au travail à la fac au bureau
vous bossez que j'ai donc été
probablement moins sans vos smartphones
dont tournoi sur ses smartphones on peut
arriver le jour fin deuxième journée
votre smartphone doit être extrêmement
gaillard s'est pas là où vous allez
faire le plus de choses que vous pouvez
y arriver
si par contre vous l'utiliser de façon
bien plus intensive une journée vous les
avez vous les avez sans aucun problème
et ça ça me paraît être la moindre des
choses est relativement normal pour des
smartphones très haut de gamme
maintenant la différence d'autonomie
entre le s20 et le s20 plus vu qu'on a
500 clients père heures de différence on
est aussi un écran un peu plus petits un
écran un peu plus grand pour moi ça joue
dans un mouchoir de poche et je vois pas
réellement de différence entre le s20 et
le s20 plus donc une deuxième point pour
moi qui est liée à la batterie il n'est
pas non plus extrêmement important donc
pour l'instant reste juste sans le poids
du format qui est pour moi un des points
décisifs
on continue sur la partie photo parce
que oui il ya une différence sur la
partie photo alors il ya une différence
mais dans les faits il n'y a pas
réellement de différence je vous
explique
dans les deux cas les chefs se présente
de la manière forte
vous avez ici votre capteur principal
qui est un grand angle de 12 mégapixels
qui ouvre à f 1.8 ça c'est pareil dans
les deux cas ici vous avez votre ultra
grand-angle
c'est également un 12 mégapixels sauf
que lui il va ouvrir à f 2.2 vous allez
avoir qu'ici en dessous un capteur de 64
mégapixels qui lui va ouvrir à f 2.0
vous avez de la stabilisation optique
soit capteur principal vous avez la
stabilisation optique bien évidemment
sur le téléobjectif sur l' ultra
grand-angle vous n'en avez pas ici celle
grand-angle et ici c'était l'objectif
là je sais pas pourquoi vous et dessiner
ça y est absolument rien ces mots qui
délire vous avez ici un petit flash led
mais il ya une différence je sais pas si
vous la voyez si elle vous saute aux
yeux vous avez un capteur de plus sur le
s20 plus ici tu juste là ici c'est ce
qu'on appelle la caméra tof qui va venir
mesurer la distance entre vous lorsqu'on
vient vous prendre en photo le
smartphone et là vous vous êtes là et
entre eux le fond vous avez que ce soit
des immeubles que ce soit ce que vous
voulez ça va calculer pour vraiment vous
sortir un flou d'arrière-plan vous soyez
net et tout ça ça soit floue la question
est est-ce qu'il ya un quelconque
intérêt à avoir une caméra tough à 100
euros d'écart est ce que vous allez
faire beaucoup de photos avec le mode
portrait
d'autant plus que je sais pas si vous
avez regardé mais je voulais présenter
lors de mon test du samsung galaxy ace
va ultra et bien globalement les
nouveaux smartphones de samsung et sharp
a extrêmement bien les hautes lumières
lorsque vous allez faire des photos en
mode portrait donc est ce que vous allez
faire beaucoup de photos en mode
portrait et j'en suis pas convaincu donc
de fait est ce qu on a une différence
qui est liée à la photo bah je n'en suis
pas persuadé donc
donc ça c'est bien mais c'est pas
suffisant il ya aussi une différence qui
va se faire au niveau du stockage
parce que sur le s20 et sur le s20 plus
vous avez dans les deux cas 128
gigaoctets de stockage sauf que oui mais
pas réellement il ya une différence
c'est que sur le s ventes plus vous
allez pouvoir monter jusqu'à 500 12 giga
de stockage et uniquement sur le modèle
5 g alors vous avez effectivement un
modèle 5 g qui existe sur l'ès 20 mais
vous l'aurez uniquement en 128 go de
stockage
bon alors ça c'est bien la partie du
stockage elle est importante mais elle
est surtout lié un dernier point qui est
le sixième point qui pour moi est d'un
point les plus importants avec le format
c est la question du prix parce qu'un
amoureux dotés de smartphones ils sont
pas gratuits et s'est souvent arrêté ces
deux smartphones il existe dans deux
configurations différentes une version
4g est une version 5 g sans le s20 ultra
la question se pose pas il est
uniquement 5 g mais là par contre on a
le choix
bon alors ça c'est bien mais pour moi
c'est une question qui est un peu merdé
je vous explique pourquoi
parce qu'en fait vous avez le choix
entre deux technologies collection
réseau la 4g que vous connaissent
actuellement que vous utilisez
probablement depuis de nombreuses années
dont vous connaissez rien de nouveau au
dessus par contre vous avez la 5g
aujourd'hui la 5g c'est l'inconnu on ne
connaît pas les tarifs des opérateurs
devraient donc vous dire ok si j'achète
un smartphone plus cher de les étaler
dans quelques instants
si donc je fais l'investissement
financier qu'est ce que je vais
réellement avoir alors on s'est
effectivement aujourd'hui que la 5g ira
plus vite que la 4g mais ça c'est juste
la partie émergée de l'iceberg
il ya bien évidemment la 5g en terme de
connexion connexion rapide mais aussi
une deuxième cinq jeux qui va arriver en
termes de connectivité tous vos
appareils interconnectés il ya la 5g qui
va être la grosse révolution des objets
connectés ce qu'on appelle les yachts y
ait aujourd'hui c'est compliqué de
dire ok je vais mettre plus d'argent sur
un smartphone alors qu'on n'arrive même
pas à imaginer ce que vous allez avoir
comme bien un gain de vitesse de
collection sans imaginer mais tout le
reste aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué
de l'anticiper donc ça reste une
question un peu délicate et c'est pour
ça que je dis c'est une question qui est
relativement merdeuse on l'a donc des
tarifs différents ici sur smartphone de
base le s20 enquête chez vous êtes à 909
euros
si vous voulez la même chose là dessus
il faut rajouter plus 100 euros vous les
calculs c'est très simple vous passez à
1900 euros
si maintenant vous voulez le s20 en
version 5 g que vous voyez l'intérêt de
la 5g que voulait comment vous projeter
dans les années à venir parce que c'est
un smartphone que vous allez garder
longtemps et bien vous allez rajouter
100 euros de plus ici c'est à dire que
c'est un smartphone que vous allez payer
1000 9 euros exactement au même tarif
que vous allez acheter le s20 plus en 4g
dont vous voyez sont à la diagonale des
prix à prendre en considération entre le
s20 plus 4g ou le s20 5 g d'où le fait
de réfléchir à tout ça et on dirait dans
quelques instants tandis que si vous
voulez le s20 + 5 g et c'est là que ça
devient intéressant
vous avez soit la version en 128 giga de
stockage soit la version en 512 jia de
stockage
si vous voulez la version 128 go de
stockage sabots coûtera une île 109
euros parce que oui une fois de plus on
passe les plus 100 euros c'est pas
pourquoi ils ont décidé ça chez samsung
est par contre si vous voulez la version
5 g ici c'est pas plus 100 euros
c'est plus 150 euros allez savoir
pourquoi
vous êtes donc un 1259 euros j'y viens
plus 150 par rapport à la version 128 go
de stockage par contre s'ils voulaient
vraiment la différence par rapport aux
angevins plus 4g et wazin +5 2 512 go de
stockage voyez ça fait plus 250 euros
donc là il ya quand même un vrai cap
mais une fois de plus vous arrivez sur
un plus gros stockage ça me coûte se
poser la question
donc la question du stockage elle se
pose uniquement sur la configuration s20
+ 5 g en 512
est ce que pour vous c'est important
d'avoir 512 jr de stockage tout en
sachant que vous avez en plus une carte
micro sd
si vous ne pouvez monter votre
smartphone jusqu'à au moins un terrain
sans aucun problème dont gerry dans tous
les cas le modèle s 20 + 5 g 512 go de
stockage
je n'oublierai or besoins particuliers
la version 512 giga de stockage à gan
1259 euros on l'oubli on se pose donc la
question entre ces trois tarifs 1109
euros mille neuf mille neuf et 909 et en
fait on revient à nos problématiques
importantes
on a dégagé la question du stockage et
on se retrouve donc
deux problèmes le problème numéro un qui
est la question du format est le
problème numéro 2 qui est la question du
prix mais la question du prix soulève
une autre question c'est la question de
la 4g versus 5 g est lente et comment
parce que je sais un j'imagine vous vous
dites ok smartphone 5g l'asean
logiquement arriver
est ce que ça vaut le coup je sais pas
c'est le briolet vous me parlez de
transition quelques maires nous parce
que j'ai pas beaucoup sont aujourd'hui
j'aurais peut-être pas je suis désolé si
ça peut vous offusquer mais c'est pareil
un peu compliqué parce que il faut
commencer à lancer la machine il faut
commencer à vendre des terminaux 5g pour
vous puissiez vous avoir la 5g quand les
offres seront disponibles sur vos
opérateurs sauf qu'aujourd'hui le
bénéfice de la 5g on le calcule pas
nécessairement on le voit pas
nécessairement on peut le cas que d'un
point de vue financier ce que ça va vous
coûter
du point de vue du device ici mais pas
forcément du point de vue de
l'abonnement un abonnement 5 jégo côté
forcément plus cher que ce que vous
payez aujourd'hui sur l'abonnement kg il
ya bien évidemment tous les coups des
équipementiers il ya tout plein de
choses qui vont arriver avec donc ça
forcément coûter plus cher j'imagine
pour emmener du monde à la 5g
vous allez avoir des offres sur une
première année du point de vue des
opérateurs parce que si un opérateur
arrive je sais pas moi si vous avez un
appareil par exemple un abonnement à 30
euros par mois
je pensais un peu au hasard quand vous
dès maintenant votre abonnement vous
coûter 40 45 euros par mois du jour au
lendemain vous n'allez pas switcher sur
la 5g vous êtes vous dire pourquoi je
voulais rajouter de l'argent
porto qui permettra d'aller plus vite
alors qu'aujourd'hui ce que j'aime
convient relativement bien d'autant plus
que la 5g va concerner une partie des
zones en france même si la couverture va
être quand même relativement large au
début et va s'étendre
il ya plein de jeunes qui ne l'auront
pas notamment les zones rurales et les
villes intermédiaires et les villages
donc la question de la 5g tout de suite
et touche pas tout le monde à mon avis
confèrent les opérateurs on le verra ça
va pas tarder à arriver c'est que il
risque de vous proposer des forfaits
5 j'ai quasiment au même tarif que ce
que vous allez avoir eu de la 4g pour
vous emmener sur l'abonnement 5g aux
mêmes tarifs pendant probablement un an
et ensuite bim
on arrive seul vrai tarifs sauf que
entre temps vous aurez expérimenter la
5g vous aurez vu l'intérêt
potentiellement est ce que ça vous aura
convaincu ou pas et une fois qu'on a mis
le pied dedans le général on y reste la
question aujourd'hui de se dire est-ce
que je pars sur un device 4g ou un
device 5g cinq questions et ennuyante
préféré que samsung tranche et se
mouiller un peu plus autant ils sont
mouillés avec le s20 ultra mais c'est un
peu facile parce que ses smartphones qui
fait ce qu'il ya de mieux on n'aura pas
pu vous voir ce qui se fait de mieux
sans vous mettre de la 5g sauraient pas
le sens là par contre on vous laisse le
choix et ça reste malgré tout un choix
peu cornélien alors de mon point de vue
comment technophiles et en regardant un
peu ce qui se passe en ayant vu un peu
les opérateurs en ayant bu pas mal
tourner à gauche
je pense qu'aujourd'hui si vous avez les
moyens si financièrement ça passe
acheter un smartphone 5g parce que vous
allez avoir un vrai gap la cinquième
année du temps à s'installer la 5g d'un
point vue purement connexion il va y
avoir un réel intérêt parce que vous
allez avoir des débits beaucoup plus
intéressant mais la 5g c'est bien plus
que ça on va pas sans compte en 2020
peut-être un petit peu en 2021 mais
surtout en 2022
la question aujourd'hui c'est vous
acheter un smartphone est ce que vous
allez l'acheter pour un an est-ce que
vous allez changer l'année prochaine ou
est ce que vous comptez le garder deux
ans trois ans à ce calme malgré tout un
investissement
si vous comptez le garder deux ans trois
ans vous invite tout de suite acheté un
smartphone 5g pour être vraiment
compatible avec les offres qui vont
arriver est vraiment pas louper le coche
technologique c'est en tout cas le
conseil que je peux vous donner
mais une fois de plus c'est pas mal
moins 10 des finances pas moi qui était
la clé de votre budget donc ça ça dépend
des fois de plus de vous si vous en avez
la possibilité
prenez de la série g n'allez pas sur
laquelle j'ai si maintenant c'est un peu
compliqué vous allez sur la 4g vous
aurez un très bon appareil avec
exactement les mêmes performances nous
un truc qui marche parfaitement bien il
vous serez pas déçus mais rien ne vous
empêchera dans un an et demi deux ans si
vous pouvez vous le permettre de
basculer sur un smartphone 5 g bon alors
la question 4g versus 5 g s'est résolu
donc toute la partie les gadjé en double
il nous reste donc à trancher entre deux
modèles soit un modèle qu'on va payer
1000 9 euros soit un modèle qu'on va
payer 1109 laurent on a donc un écart de
100 euros entre deux modèles donc on en
revient là qu'est ce qui va vous faire
dépenser 100 euros de plus ou 100 euros
de moins
et bien c'est une fois de plus la
question du format
bon alors c'est pas que j'étais
contorsionniste je vais pas vous refaire
à la question du choix du format ça
dépend une fois de plus de vous ça
dépend de votre taille demain ça dépend
si vous voulez un petit format ou en
grand format
mais pour moi la vraie grosse différence
elle va se faire là dessus sur la
tronche et ce en termes d'expérience
multimédia ils vont se relever puisque
je sais que d'un point de vue purement
qualitatif
j'ai vraiment tout ça sur les deux
modèles c'est mon blog commun dans les
deux cas ça marche maintenant tu
vraiment faire mon choix entre 6,2 et
6,7 pousse ici c'est clairement pas du
tout une question à se poser entre d'un
côté les hommes et d'un côté les femmes
parce que ça dépend pas du tout ça ça
dépend réellement je dirais de la taille
de
vos mains si vous avez des grandes mains
des petites mains oui ça je sais c'est
une main les jets d'acide extrêmement
mal ça va surtout dépendre de la
question de vos usages
une fois de plus alors si on prend un
smartphone très haut de gamme c'est
qu'on va avoir des usages variés vous
allez avoir des usages en termes de
multi média youtube ça va être netflix
ça va être tout ce que vous voulez donc
du visionnage vidéo ça va être aussi le
jeu vidéo ça va être
en plus je dirais le confort de
visionnage ça dépend de votre vision est
ce que vous êtes plus à l'aise avec un
écran de 6,7 pouces avec un écran de 6,2
pouces donc la question du confort
visionnage elle est aussi liée à la
question de vos yeux est-ce que vous
avez des pathologies choses comme ça si
et sortent vraiment sont des professeurs
quand je fais ça c'est incroyable
bien évidemment dans le multimédia j'ai
oublié toutes les questions d'instagram
toutes les questions de tik tok les
questions de facebook snapshot et
compagnie donc en fait on a trois gros
points à se poser si vous avez des mains
qui sont pas trop grande un peu petit
vous allez sur lèze
si vous avez des mains de bûcheron je
vais enlever pour boucheron un radar et
stéréotypes
vous allez sur le s20 plus ça c'est
uniquement cette question là si
maintenant vous êtes dans les usages
multimédias et que vous voulez du
confort de visionnage
non pas pour des questions de
problématiques de vos yeux mais vous
voulez vraiment être tranquille
moi ce que je vous conseille c'est le
s20 plus et si vous avez des pathologies
s20 plus parce que si on revient petit
peu à ce qui se fait en 2020 une taille
d'écran de 6,2 pouces
c'est quelque chose de très moyen on est
sur un format un petit peu standard par
contre 6 9 7 pouces on fait partie quand
même des grands écrans donc ya vraiment
un choix à faire et ce choix là
malheureusement pas faire votre place
qui donne vraiment les clés la question
des usages la question des formats la
question de votre main dont bien
évidemment il ya aussi la question du
tarif
donc tout ce bazar on va essayer de s'y
retrouver pour récapituler un peu les
choses clairement
on a donc deux smartphones le s20 le s20
plus pour moi le s20 c'est le petit
format qui est quand même aujourd'hui
relativement compact par rapport à ce
qu'on peut trouver en 2020 qui sera
super en termes de technologie il ya
beaucoup tu es moins cher vous allez
pouvoir avoir bien évidemment de la 5g
et tout ça à 1900 euros
si par contre vous voulez un grand
format qui est vraiment optimisé pour le
multi média qui est vraiment un des
usages les plus importants aujourd'hui
en 2000
et bien vous allez sur le galaxy ace va
plus en 5 g qui vous coûtera 1000 109
euros
donc pour un écart 200 euros on fait le
choix entre deux côtés du multimédia et
de l'autre côté un format compact la
réalité elle est là dessus et le choix
ils sont là dessus merci monsieur
alors bien évidemment tout ça c'est pour
faire un comparatif maintenant on va
passer à autre chose
ah oui forcément la bête en jeu vous
aider à choisir entre ces deux
smartphones vont dire lequel est le plus
intéressant entre le s20 et d20 plus
j'étais quand même tester et il faut que
je donne mon retour pour vous dire ses
smartphones est-ce qu'ils sont
intéressants parce j'ai fait extrêmement
rapidement ce qui est déjà très très
long pour vous donner les points très
importante aux smartphones et vous dire
réellement ce que jamais dessus au delà
du côté spec ce smartphone il à l'écran
qui est vraiment incroyable
côté multimédia pour tout ce que vous
voulez la qualité est vraiment vraiment
super top l'audio titre est très cool
avec deux par leurs haut-parleurs ici et
haut-parleurs là il ya un côté très
immersif lorsque vous allez écouter en
plus c'est très fort vous avez beaucoup
de son don pour rester comme en
multimédia
c'est vraiment génial en termes de
performances exynos 990 marche
extrêmement bien couple et 8 gigas de
ram ou 12 igad ramf un modèle 5 g le
seul truc que j'ai remarqué c'est un
tout petit peu de chf
ici dans la partie centrale lorsqu'on
utilise vraiment on est un capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est
extrêmement actif et qui est donc très
très rapidement tout ça tourne sur au
moins deux qui marchent merveilleusement
bien tout est très bien compartimenter
c'est clair on peut régler plein de
choses pour moi la surcouche est
vraiment cool et vous tombez bien
évidemment sur une base android dix
jeunes quelques photos du galaxy s
vagues sont prises aux états unis à new
york là on doit être du côté de harlem
je trouve vraiment bien capteur
principal ça marche extrêmement bien
luttera quand on est un peu moins précis
on capte moins de lumière mais ça fait
son effet lorsque vous êtes beaucoup
lumière extérieure sinon c'est à oublier
lorsqu'on s'approche comme joliet clown
x 3 ça marche chez vous vous rapprochez
beaucoup trop tôt tu ton père en qualité
et des vous avez surtout une fois trente
ans pas se mentir c'est dégoûtant
ça c'est tout et c'est ce que j'ai fait
est que le mode single take je me suis
filmé en vidéo voyez ça me sens pas mal
de choses différentes photos en noir et
blanc différents rendus avec différentes
colorimétrie bombasse a fait le taf
là c'est le mode portrait alors le mode
portrait avec le s20 il est pas mal mais
il n'est pas complètement ouf
voyez au niveau des cheveux il a un
petit peu de mal ici à détourer par
rapport aux fonds et la nuit par contre
ça marche extrêmement bien qu'une belle
préservation des couleurs des détails on
a des choses qui sont vraiment bourgade
et l'arrière là on va bientôt détail
s'est pas créé mais on a bien le visage
des gens devant on voit bien tous les
côtés pour voir connaître du mouvement
moi je trouve ça vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien alors bien évidemment sur
lui très grand-angle tout de suite c'est
beaucoup
un bien parce que c'est pas stabilisée
c'est très difficile surtout pour moi
mais de quoi sur le capteur principal ça
marche même si on vient zoom et un tout
petit peu ça fonctionne mais si on vient
zoom est beaucoup trop une fois de plus
on va dire perdre en qualité
voilà des photos qui sont prises avec le
s20 plus lent mais dans le métro à new
york regardez on voit très bien les
détaillants bas le ciel est pas cramé il
ya très très bon équilibre très très
très beau travail logiciel fait
là-dessus en devenir humain de plus on
va perdre qui peut en qualité ce qui
n'est pas anormal mais dans l'absolu que
ce soit sur le s20 ou le s20 plus de
rendu au niveau des photos est vraiment
extrêmement qualitatif photo nuit c'est
exactement la même chose vous allez voir
sur le s20 et le s ventes plus sont les
mêmes capteurs vous avez même processeur
derrière l'église 990
on a exactement la même chose en terme
de ram donc le rendu est exactement le
même la vraie différence je voulais dit
tout à l'heure elle se fait bien
évidemment sur le capteur tough donc ce
soit des photos nues il faut toujours
des photos nourriture c'est exactement
la même chose
voilà vous savez tout sur ses deux
nouveaux smartphones de samsung n120 est
20 plus également les voix ultra mais je
vous renvoie une fête plus dans ma vidéo
test pour tout savoir ce matin est
extrêmement bien aussi très performant
très puissant maintenant vous savez
exactement ce qu'ils ont dit vous savez
faire votre choix je vous invite si vous
intéresse à passer par les liens vous
avez en bas dans la description profite
d'un petit coup de main et de faire
évoluer la chaîne donc ça c'est plutôt
cool
une fois de plus vous invite à vous
abonner et aime dire c'est des tests
comme ça vous intéresse est ce que ça
vous intéresse qu on décortique tout et
que je dise à la fin c'est celui-là
qu'il vous faut si vous êtes dans ce cas
là c'est celui là si vous êtes dans ce
cas là tu vois si ce format de test
comparatif vous plaît bien évidemment
ils établissent une fois de plus des
jolies pousse à vous abonner pas vous
connaissez l'histoire surtout fait des
gros bisous jeu rendez vous dès demain
pour continuer à parler de teck il ya
plein de choses à venir il ya plein de
produits plein de nouveautés on en
pleine phase de lancement de plein de
produits sur toutes les grandes
nouveautés on s'est un peu compliqué en
ce moment à cause du corona des russes
il peut pas y avoir de grands lancements
comme on le fait un petit peu
habituellement c'est plus des petits
rendez vous avec les différents
journalistes donc ce n'était pas
compliqué sur ce on fait quand même avec
on va voir les produits on va quand même
les voir donc je vous en parlais de vie
donc à vous abonner et se passe juste
ici si ce n'est pas déjà le cas sur ce
je vous embrasse le rendez vous de
demain on continue à parler de taxe tenu
à parler d'eux tech
j'arrive plus à parler
bon
non
le patriote
et pour le web
les bénévoles et les autres
où est le seul téléphone